my name is Alan Tudyk and I'm with our
met my name's Ben Mendelsohn and I'm
doing wide autocomplete interview to
auto-complete in the view that correct
yes correct
I'm just testing don't worry do you
relax stay there and what you want what
we do
you ready it's Felicity Jones Eddie
Redmayne well what do you mean clearly
not I know I think that's a joke though
ah it's a joke Oh jokes this is true
that is a Felicity Jones who's a nudist
and it's not you and it's not me are us
no water water oh yeah yeah seriously
Oh notice there's no were there what
else so he basically cuz we both got
brown hair and we have fringes no bangs
you must never say because things what
is Felicity Jones face shape like a
lemon a little bit of extra on my chin
it's a family trait does resume it drink
alcohol that sounds like that smart what
my mom's been googling as long as I'm
depressing fans why is it just my family
members googling me to find out how
religiously observant I what does resume
it mean so I asked myself the question
every day every day every day I ask
myself that question what is the
significance of me what does it refer me
to so you know in a way this isn't about
googling this is just an insight into my
own mind the dark recesses of my own
insecurities so thank you this is for
all of us I guess it's rock one Star
Wars eight Star Wars eight now you're so
wrong whoever I mean no not entirely
however it is the eighth film in the
Star Wars series of films so you could
say yes but you could also say no
because it's a standalone film of its
own film happens between Episode four
and three it's Star Wars 3.5 or 3.85
Israel one going to be it's wrong one
going to be good good it's gonna be
awesome
damn good yeah it's broke one a movie No
you'll become he'll become a call
life-changing experience they it's rogue
one a trilogy we cannot answer that
Roblin is rough one rogue one about Leia
this is getting day maybe is where I won
a book it will be like yeah at some
point yeah where the Death Star
no there's one up the top here where the
Death Star where is the Death Star
where did you park it would you leave it
brother where is the Death Star trench
if you take a look at the Death Star you
will see that around what we would
equate to an idea quite exactly what I
was gonna say is where you'll see the
trench going around right where is the
dead star from built in space well where
are the where are the Death Star plans
yeah our director stole them at the end
of the movie and his flat in London
okay Isis ben mendelsohn Oh Mary
yes god those people who are not able to
read not rapid far unless you go
management-related to monitor our and
take no it's Ben Mendelsohn in bloodline
season two yes 511 none of your business
may just really dependent what do you
call lifting weights luggage carry my
tattoos no I would say no I do have one
oh yeah we got it you got it
that's my wife's Chinese mate
where does the knee onion leaves that's
easy
ah eat guys ever heard of Tyrion it
smells like smells like garbage right
but you see that you hate it all you
love it and I love it
what is Donnie and best movie and Darth
Vader's Ken Darth Vader tap don'ts I'm
guessing porpoise use force lightning we
would you remember okay probably can
Darth Vader eat I imagine him eating
like a straw I'm not sure if you can but
does he need to is the bigger question
where did he sustain himself through
people's fears in the darkness of the
universe Oh like he's gonna sit down
like heart you can do that like a
fast-food restaurant I know thank you I
don't need to eat because people are
scared of me so I'm good look he he
takes in nutrient through the tubes and
he likes to have a nice bath you to
bother
yes can there be there breathe in space
he has asthma yeah
difficulty too much your smoke you can't
breathe in space because there is
nothing to breathe well I guess they're
assuming that what he's breathing is
something like an oxygen supply from an
oxygen tank but it's not it's more of a
kind of filtration system all right so
can Darth Vader read mine wait what's
going on like you know what I mean like
yeah yeah and he can tell you if he
didn't read vibes yeah he's a vibrator
vibrators weird vibe these are called
vibrators I got the only free this is
great yeah Alan Tudyk
[Laughter]
and I can see why you would ask that I'm
from Texas
how tall is Alan Tudyk another top five
eleven and a half
value that half is Alan Tudyk in in
ranked are you are you friend let me
tell you a little story
well there is a NASA mating this is soon
Anthony Rapp and he and I look wildly
similar in pictures next to one another
we do not look anywhere near as much
alike but now I'm you know I booked up
how old is Alan Tudyk I'm 45 years old
no way yeah man what Oh movies is Alan
Tudyk in 35 miles from normal patch
Adams 28 days hearts in Atlantis
Knight's Tale serenity but then there
was one before that
I remember come on keep going come on
mrs. fun does Diego Luna passing likes
yes I do sing beautiful I sang in the
film book of life but there was a lot of
tweaking those diva luna have a sister
yes I didn't I do I have a lovely sister
her name is Maria and she lives in
Mexico and I'm gonna send kisses to my
sister can you what this Diego Luna say
on Conan Oh I teach him the expression
no mommies which I'm about to teach you
okay no mom is I mean literally means do
not suck right it's like I don't suck
okay no mamas no mamas no ma'am I
wouldn't be this Diego Luna play in
right now it's called rock one it's a
tiny independent film it's a Star Wars
story film in fact needs your support
what language is this Diego Luna speak
Chinese Chinese my Chinese is awesome my
English as you can tell is horrible
my Spanish is kind of okay and that's it
does rogue one this is for everyone
everyone
have Jedi's no yes to secret secrets
officials know yes it may be a crook
Darth Vader is in the move nothing's
clear does rogue one have Darth Vader
haven't we just don't have a sailor does
Darth Vader drink does rod one die does
rogue one guys well we know the answer
to that question around about the time
of New Year rogue one is a spaceship
there you go
next come on next we are why does rogue
one have different characters why does
it have different characters so
different carriers from the other movies
no but why doesn't just have one
character like being John Malkovich
wasn't a space version of that I think
it's asking what it's like it's a it's a
standalone so it's a standalone movie
that stands alone
Ezra one Buddha they've always been sort
of scrambled in the order there were
three and then they went back to three
and then they went up to seven and now
we're going back to three point eight
five or three point five depending on
who you talk to
[Music]